[Musique]
oui oui oui ça va bien qu'est-ce qui va
pas toujours qui vous gêne mais tu es
tout bizarre enfin qu'est ce qui vous
gêne
mais qu'est ce que tu as froid pour mais
comme quoi tu t'es mis ça dans la bouche
mais parce que je pense de la bouteille
ah oui ah ben c'est pas mal hein c'est
un reste de ton expérience oui parce
qu'il nous a préparés encore les oui
parce que c'est encore une x
bienveillance à face de liquide caisse
abbazi est ce qu on dit à nos amis
qu'est ce qu'on dit qu'est ce qu'on dit
quand on commence qu'est ce qu'on dit
j'espère dit mardi nous voilà maintenant
on dit pas nous voilà on dit bonjour à
bangui bout alors on dit bonjour veux tu
dire bonjour
veux tu dire bonjour bon d'accord voilà
alors excusé le but aujourd'hui est un
petit peu petit peu fou c'est pas grave
car dans l'ensemble il nous a tous bien
préparé je crois une expérience très
intéressante alors c'est la bouteille
magique c'est quoi ça avez vous des
images il bat les plaines pas remplies
d'un liquide coloré oui pour qu'on le
voit un peu le voir alors tu vas voir
fabrice on retire le bouchon retire le
bouche à bouche on y regarde dans le bas
de la bouteille en même temps qu'elle
sera repassé attention ouah ans qui
lance une bouteille en plastique bien
entendu voilà ça cool très bien on se
dit c'est la catastrophe ça va tout
inondé ben oui alors rebelles bouchons
alors genre mais le bouchon là et tu
vois rebouche mieux voilà me sens bien
ça et ça s'arrête et voilà à cet
étonnant sata murs étaient patents ça et
tu alors donc personne qui trouve gens
là dans la bouteille en plastique c'est
bien ça exactement je ne fais pas trop
gros quand même nom ce que si les plus
les gros le trou plus c'est difficile
d'arrêter je suis né semble alors une
épingle munipal alors pouvait faire la
même chose vous prenez une bouteille en
plastique vous le remplissez de liquide
coloré ou percer un trou avec une
épingle et à volonté
vous faites marcher le système en
débouchant la bouteille up et ça marche
vraiment très lents très très très bien
mais cette fois fois récipiendaire oui
bien sûr on va faire une saleté un petit
bac es
cuvette n'apporte qu'est ce qu'on veut
et ensuite on lahrech en rebouchant et
ça s'arrête ça s'arrête ça s'arrête ça
s'arrête à la taille très bien là tu
vois même fait tomber ça s'est arrêté
c'est formidable s'il y avait une petite
mimiques qu'il a quelque chose de rigolo
dans le visage avec qu'est ce que tu
peux faire avec mon fils oui mais je
sais pas moi ce que tu manges tu abuses
nous tu veux je te fasse un bouchon mais
le bouchon pendant les de la bouteille
là le bruit on ne fait pas ça qu'est ce
qui va se passer mais non mais y regarde
bien rien tu vas être humain et ses
grands tu fais toi
assez pour moi là alors gare à toi c'est
presque ça c'est pas évidemment toi tu
le fais avec ton bex et puis quand même
moi j'ai pas de baker je le fais
autrement on se débrouille bien a paraît
il faut pas le faire chez vous lorsqu'il
ya des invités comme ça brusquement à
table mais lorsque vous êtes entre amis
pour vous amuser à le faire je m'en vais
et d'or au sabre is hardcore il faire
alors je trouve encore des choses
terribles
je le sens arroser les fleurs qui a
préparé un oui il est sentie lui il est
sorti ça y est oui non oui oui oui
le point commun alors on raconte chacun
mais on a et on a chacun quelque chose
encore à kabala alors tu peux ouvrir
voilà voilà voilà
est-ce que c'est difficile ah c'est
toujours diffusée tous les jours
difficiles dans sa vie devant toi tu es
jeune bien voilà je suis bien bon tu es
prêt pour le point corolla là bas alors
voilà aujourd'hui fabrice moi je suis un
arbre un an les abcès la forêt moi je
connais bien les arts puisque loi
j'habite dans les arbres j'ai un deux
pièces résine à l'abri donc je viens de
ces absences nerfs tu vois comme on en
voit au plus profond des forêts oui et
je joue à cache cache avec des hiboux
avec des chasseurs et je crois que
d'ailleurs je suis le plus vieux de la
forêt en tout cas je suis le plus haut
le plus sony parce que étant le plus
haut et le plus solide je m'accroche tu
vois les tempêtes les orages pouf je dis
pauvre je m'en moque
ah bon alors voilà c'est alors passer ça
c'est samedi c'est moi qui me raconte
tout ça c'est pour m'embrouiller c'était
moi maintenant fameux rivasi bel bel et
bien moi je suis très délicate à saisir
je suis presque est visible je suis un
cheveu très fin très léger cheveux
blonds légèrement tendus les je ne suis
pas comme tout encore tout qu'encore moi
je crains les orages et les tempêtes
dès qu'il pleut dit qu'il ya du vent
j'entends les femmes se plaindre sont
les cheveux dans les yeux non mise en
plis fiche mais il faut me voir sous le
soleil
je suis s'éclate on parle envie de me
prendre il me mettre bien à l'abri dans
un médaillon s'est dit assez bien c'est
petit c'est à moi we wish et à moi m'a
alors moi je suis une dent ouais et
voyez une de celles qui sont là là et
j'en ai pas beaucoup ça mais c'est pour
ça que j'y tiens beaucoup aussi
quand j'étais jeune j'en avais toute une
rangée j'étais bel bien blanche
éclatante et je pouvais manger tout ce
que je voulais ah oui et je vais même
vous dire je cassais des noix entre mes
dents et j'ai maintenant je suis obligé
de faire très attention
vous imaginez un peu ce qui se passerait
si si j'en perdais une année non pas y
penser ça serai frais fruits
voilà donc alors résumons tout ça je ne
fais pas si vous avez eu le temps de
trouver le point commun qui existe entre
eux
ces trois lascars résumons tu m'as dit
ou quand je suis un arbre un arbre à
nabeul oui belle belle je suis très
délicate je suis un cheveu un ce genre
de cheveux
oui
maintenant j'avoue qu'au début je
n'avais pas trouvé
et puis finalement ce qui m'a mis sur la
voie ces pousses monsieur à cet incident
m'a parlé de dents j'ai fait le
rapprochement avec l'arbre car elle
n'avait pas pensé aux cheveux en fait
vous et de quoi il s'agit c'est une
racine c'est ça oui mais qui peut
racines de la racine du cheveu et
racines de là dedans
et voilà nous avons tous les cars elle
dit retrouver c'était très bien
la drogue chez ben quoi alors moi bon
annoncer mon jeu oui mon jeu à oui mais
ça va faire mal
bah oui ça va ça va quoi abbas la
chambre qui a bien fait attention à
l'orthographe
alors j'y vais avant alors tu vas
attendre qu'ils tableau oui bon t'as ton
crayon
oui le voilà bon alors cette fois ci
c'est un mot ans il être un si l'être
humain j'écoute alors la première lettre
ses seins elle
bon elle moi je veux bien à elle
oui après alors après tu fais quatre
petits traits qui représente les lettres
mon contre 1,2 que tu dois trouver cap
et la dernière lettre c'est un thé comme
mon ami tout quand tu étais comme tout
concourt à la ola à la alors ma centrale
qu'est l'art alors je pose deux
questions vas-y vas-y vas-y je t'écoute
en moi je tombe toujours tout de suite
avant est ce que c'est un animal
ah bah oui oh bah oui je pense que je
sais que tu adores sahraoui ça je ne me
trompe pas en ce moment et problème
n'est pas réglé à un animal à plumes
non non non animale à poil là non non
non un animal tout au nom il est pas
tout neuf en faire un animal qui mangent
de l'herbe
non pas spécialement une molaire il
n'aime pas manger la viande non plus
vous c'est pas de la viande les insectes
ah oui oui oui j'étais un petit animal
alors eu un petit animal gentil petit
animal j'en ai redit veux tu que je te
donne une lettre la rue a peut-être oui
ça va tirer quand même - la td maroc
revient mais alors la quatrième lettre
la quatrième c1 tient à aa
voilà voilà voilà
alors maintenant hâte retrouver avec un
elle pour commencer est-ce que sa rampe
ah oui ah oui ça arrange a remporté sa
8e un toucan s'arrangeant mais est ce
que est ce que ça va vite
ah ça va assez vite ou y seraient vie ça
va très vite même à votre ironie masse
alors nous on y va ça alors vite que
lima sort était lié au centre
d'orthographe
oui l'album highway est ce que est ce
que puisque ce que c'est un animal
domestique nous nom d'animal sauvage vie
autrement il vibre banque est libre où
il est donc il va vite il va me courent
mamans toutes les forêts oui beaucoup à
queue dans le froid des fois ça reste au
soleil tranquillement assad et murray
sont des petits murs à plat quand on
s'approche voets assembler sur des
murets et ça y est ah bon enfin ça y est
ça doit pas aller ça comment les arts
ribas et ça ça tombe bien comment ça
allait ça commence à les arts comment tu
écris les a repoussés au sud a que très
fâché a maintenant te fâche pas je vais
et époux smooth et comment écrit tu les
arbres l e z à rt et voilà sa robe comme
en chantant le zr100 j'ai encore fait
une faute d'orthographe
enfin pouces moussu tout courant va
tenir comment écrit tous les autres
encore comment tu écris le
za rt1 et je te dire ce n'était pas ça
alors elle eseda rh à je suis vraiment
complètement épuisé jake fox a regardé
comme on écrit les arts
l e z a il faut que j'écrive bien parce
que sinon on va pas pouvoir les airs et
des eaux voilà les arts les jardins
voilà les arts les arts avec un des oui
avec un des aubaines oui j'étais en
train de me demander d'ailleurs sur
mettez un accent aigu non ce qui est
pour la peine est entendu qu'il en est
de la voilà c'est peut-être pas utile
les arabes à vue à balader avec un dur
en tête incroyable quand même pas et
c'est quand même pas une grosse faute de
quoi une énorme faute est une faute
colossal je me suis juste trompé pour la
dernière lettre le petit bunker jeunes
quatre cas ça me fait penser que tu sais
peut-être parce atteint les lézards
quand on les attrape un par le bout de
la queue bas ils se sauvent et vous
laisse dans la main ce petit bout de
queue si oui et ça leur fait pas mal du
tout s comme ça comme comme abou
d'allumettes et ils vivent très bien
comme ça 1 loi il paraît que ça repousse
nous c'est fou ah bah moi on m'a dit que
c'est repoussait mais c'est peut-être
vrai j'ai jamais eu le temps de regarder
parce qu'ils vont tellement vite à même
pas vingt quand même de ces précisions
mais je voudrais que tu travailles ton
au retour image de travail je te promets
je te promets la prochaine fois je te
promets que je fais très attention
ok dit pas pardon devrait déranger avec
une idée en spa je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être pas faire attendre bel bel
ébat oui elle est prête à un bas dans
ces conditions alors vous les savez les
artistes il faut les prendre quand ils
sont prêts au méga alors une chose que
je dis toujours oui
[Musique]
qu'elle vous ne vous rappelez
m
[Musique]
cb dépêche-toi hpc
elle nous vient vite
[Musique]
voilà
il est trop tôt
je
[Musique]
toi et moi pouvons pas la même
iba ça bastonne on ne sait pas ne fait
pas belle belle si tu cries moi je te
pleure alors jeté cision qu'est-ce que
tu mettes dans ta valise mais je ne sais
pas moi j'ai pas regardé lui pleure un
postiche moi tu es bête tu ne connais
rien tu n'as rien vu on te trouves
toujours posé là la même place
moi je te propose de deviner quoi je lui
propose de l'emmener en italie on est
allé qui nous la ville aux sept collines
florence capitale de la toscane inhabile
à naplouse
quel spectacle durant les derniers
séjours que j ai fait je me suis lié
d'amitié avec des napolitains
j'habitais chez eux je partageaient leur
repas ils mangeaient de la choucroute je
mangeais de la gironde je partageais
leurs loisirs aussi ils allaient à
l'opéra je les suivais l'opéra on va ça
va bien comme comme les belles
maintenant oui je suis un peu oui mais
sinon je la vois très éclatant photo
fabrice non mais est ce que tu es allé
en italie valbelle cette pièce
l'été dernier simplement c'est en italie
ce que tu avais pas parlé d'un voyage
aux etats-unis alors allé à new york
il faut passer par amp c'est le chemin
le plus direct en abondance que tu
ignores en bas très bien mais fabrice tu
ne sais jamais rien et se montrent
pourtant je trouve très rock et il
trouve entre 8 et 10 rue remplie perco
je suis cool un petit truc super d'en
marquer comme je suis cool je le serai
mort en suicide
mais non non je continue l'histoire il
faut arriver sur la place du capitole
je réfléchis je me dis ma fille puisque
tu es là tu dois te renier de culture
latine alors je dis 'je visite de visite
visite la capitale d'abord le pognon le
colisée on veut saint-pierre et puis et
puis et puis les catacombes
en fait tu t'arrêtes tu vois ce que je
fais des croquis alors je voyage je fais
tout les thalys mais vermeer et coutumes
à gaza abris secrets
tu me regardes ça me troue en bonne on
continue le pour ne pas que penser alors
beaucoup
alors donc l'italie oui il ya des choses
merveilleuses oui milan sa cathédrale
pise la tour penchée abel et puis et
puis c'est rapide et gratuit
bon là c'est google en avait au tennis
venez belle belle raconte venise
nouvelle à venise
bon ça brille ça me coûte 1000 mais je
connais très bien venue du magazine
hello maintenant j'aime mieux ne pas me
parler à toi parce que j'ai l'impression
que tu n'es pas tellement un écouteur va
là dessus bon alors venise ya de l'eau
mais de nous sur laquelle glisse des
gondoles c'est bien pratique un pour se
rendre d'un point à un autre
l'atmosphère à venir est d'une folle
d'été car tous les gondoliers se
connaissent
tu sais fabrice au pays dont je ne parle
pas fabrice quand leur jardin
on se croise les gondoliers se saluent
en rejetant à l'air leurs bonnets de
fourrure et des échanges qu'elle chante
tu mens mènera à venise les secrets que
s'il te plaît fabrice je parle à mon
petit mobile pouces mais aussi relevé
tu sais les secrets à ses petites rues
bordées de palets de maison de bambou je
les connais tous nous nous amuserons
pousse pousse
mais si tu fais partie rage et ont pris
dix mois et le pas pour tout de ce que
tu devais être dans à bali c'est pas moi
c'est à dire une chose pour ce monsieur
si tu vas en italie comme ailier talent
et ce n'est pas la peine de préparer ta
valise du ça parce que il ya des choses
qui me paraissent bizarres dans ce qu'on
dit n'a jamais demandé à partir
c'est ce moustique est invité je dois
reconnaître le centriste ne sont pas
tristes ou encore si tu voyages aussi
loin qu'elle tue n'ira pas plus loin que
le coin de la rue n'est ce pas mme el
baile va revoir bonjour à l'italie
bonjour en co2 liées à leur écoute et ne
soyez pas désespérés de ne pas partir
parce que je vous dire une chose si
véritablement vous avez trouvé à venise
des maisons en bambou alors ça je vous
tends vous dire que si vous avez vu des
maisons en bois vo me fait signe la
choucroute caisse comme chacun sait un
plat typiquement italien la choucroute
bien entendu les bonnets de fourrure des
gondoliers vous avez déjà vu des
gondoliers avec des bonnets de fourrure
sur les cartes postales par exemple 1 1
qu'est ce qu'il ya tu vas me dire
quelque chose oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce que tu fais mais fais
attention tu vas me manger ma chemise
enfin tout cancan bon alors je vais te
dire tout ça n'a aucune importance belle
belle raconte n'importe quoi mais
finalement faisons semblant de la croire
et puis c'est tout je retourne dans la
bouteille
un oui mais qu'est ce qu'il ya mais
qu'est-ce qu'il ya du chac
mais non tout con quand elles ont un
grand garçon comme toi pouces moussu
redresse toi qu'est ce que ça veut dire
le reste toi et toi aussi
la cour a enfin tout de même fait
incroyable de les voir dans un état
pareil aux abonnés oui j'aime bien que
j'aime bien les expériences que tu nous
prépares pour qu elles sont amusantes
vous souvenez de ce qu'il a préparé tous
qu encore une bouteille de plastique un
liquide colorier un trou percé avec une
épave et hop ça va démarrer
voilà on enlève le bouchon et la
bouteille se vident automatiquement et
si vous remettez le bouchon il suffit de
quelques secondes pour que tout s'arrête
voilà qui est fait c'est une petite
expérience extrêmement simple amusante
que vous pouvez faire chez vous en
faisant bien attention de ne pas laisser
couler le liquide sur la nappe de votre
maman si non alors là j'aurais de gros
gros gros ennuis au revoir à tous
cherchez bien amusez vous bien erf est
coincé à la maison mais n'oubliez pas
sans faire de saleté au revoir à bientôt
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]